lady the new york times staying silent
after one of its star reporters gets
caught up in a firestorm for equating
trump supporters to enemies of the state
katie benner suggesting the solution to
combat domestic
national security threats is to target
voters of the former president
the smug incredibly arrogant and since
deleted tweet reads quote
today january 6 select committee
underscores the
america's current essential nat sec its
national security dilemma
work to combat legitimate national
security threats now
entails calling a current politician
supporters
enemies of the state the translation
katie is to call
supporters of president trump enemies of
the state are you an enemy of the state
i supported trump
so she's talking about 74 million
americans and the dehumanization
of political opponents throughout
history has not gone or ended well
at all and this is not the first time
we've heard this from a media that
claims to be unbiased and not liberal
we've also
heard trump supporters be compared to
the taliban
in afghanistan and what did we do to
combat the taliban we fought a 20-year
war
with the u.s military against them so
i'm not sure
how they think that this is going to end
but this language
about people who support a different
political party than you do or a certain
president
are enemies of the state the next
question is well how do you plan on
taking care of that if they're really a
national security threat
and what are you going to do if people
start defending themselves from the
threat that you're imposing on them i
mean it's almost like jesse c saying
send the authorities to come get you
yeah these liberals have violent
fantasies probably mommy issues perhaps
daddy issues
i don't have enough time to get into it
but geraldo i don't think she's a star
reporter i've never heard of her well
she's uh she is
the reporter she's never heard of this
she's the justice
department okay does she have a new york
times number one bestseller
probably not argue with me about that
and the tweet wasn't even well composed
right not even a well-composed tweet
we're talking about getting off on this
side listen
chad said there's no media bias so this
is just her being herself
she says she can separate her politics
from her job but her job is to cover
politics
and she obviously can't separate that
she's saying
dana that the failure of the democratic
party
to get trump on russia collusion and to
get him on january 6
indicates that the democratic party is
incapable of taking care of the
right-wing
crazy people so why not have a
presumption that they're all
traitors basically you can have thoughts
that you don't have to tweet
i mean that is actually there's freedom
in that very good
that is excellent there are other
journalists calling for
their peers to rise to the moment and
try to
beat back this uh basically existential
crisis that apparently we are in even
though the democrats run everything in
washington
they they do but it almost seems as if
the new york times
feels empowered to just take any shot
they want
yeah at you and then you particularly
yeah and this is how they really
feel right that's how they really feel
trump supporters are worse
and this is it just do the comparison
they are worse than looters
rioters even cop killers they're worse
than
all that there's something about it that
triggers them and it
they there needs to be a doll where they
can go to the media and they go now tell
us where trump hurt you
you know and they can point to him and
just remember every one of these people
there's more people
out there even people we know and like
have said things that make this sound
pro-trump
it's a reminder that everybody
expressing this stuff are we're wrong on
everything from 20 from 20 i don't know
in the last 20 years
the fine people hoax injecting bleach uh
hunter biden laptop right it's not just
wrong it's stupid yeah
i mean these people have never been
right on anything they've lost the
authority
on all things political and moral and we
should not take them seriously but
unfortunately
as you say they run everything not a
star reporter
am i a star reporter you are thank you
you're at large
[Laughter]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else